[Music]
this morning on the dish we raise a
glass to a drink that's gaining in
popularity in the past year wine sales
in the u.s
have risen 11 percent thanks in part to
the pandemic but one
area where sales have surged is canned
wines that's right canned wines up 68
percent from last year totaling more
than 188
million dollars selling wine in a can of
course
breaks with tradition but the industry
is taking note
dana jacobson found out how two very
different wine makers reached the same
conclusion
to sell their wine in cans
the damiano's family has been making
wine for 40 years
their pindar vineyards is the largest
and oldest family-owned winery on long
island
producing up to 70 000 cases of wine
each year
but it wasn't until 2019 that they went
from selling
strictly bottles to cans when you were a
kid around the vineyard did you ever
think
that you would be producing wine in a
can no yeah
that was the farthest part we were
always producing wines in bottle
with a cork finish no i didn't i didn't
think cans would be this popular
pindar damianos whose father dan started
the business in 1979
quickly found out otherwise selling
every single can from the winery's first
batch
there's the finished product what was it
that made you say we need to try
doing a canned wine on long island
obviously we live
on an island surrounded by beautiful
water i think the cans
give you that flexibility that
convenience to take it to the beach
go on the boat take it to the park
without having to deal with
glass and a cork and an opener i tasted
the strawberry though
although cans were new for this
generations old winery
damianos didn't want to disappoint his
loyal customers
the answer take their two most popular
wines
and sell them in smaller more portable
cans can you taste any difference at all
no they were bottled the same exact our
customers come and say is there a taste
difference and i give them a taste of
both and they can't
see a difference between the can and the
bottle
that's the winter white in the bottle
right it was something we wanted to test
for ourselves and then i have the can
it is still weird hearing it for wine
but that's okay
it's just different i shouldn't say
weird it's just different
i like that i like that really
refreshing yeah very really refreshing
with seafood and other other foods
same thing yeah soon taste and i
basically work with
vineyards and growers that are in areas
that
are not as prevalent across the country
in northern california the taste
comparison between
bottles and cans is a non-issue for wine
society
after a trip to napa valley ohio native
angela allison and her
husband austin started the company with
the plan to sell wine
strictly in a can you're the ohio girl
coming in and you're telling wine
country i want to put
wine in cans and that's it no bottles
what was that reception like
totally not what i expected and it was
actually more embracing
people were excited about it and they
realized even you know growers and
facilities that have been here for so
long
realized that there was a need for
change in the industry using grapes from
the nearby sassoon valley and some of
napa's top wine makers
wine society produces cans of red white
and rose and the industry is taking
notice
wine society's red blend tempt took a
gold medal at last year's tasters guild
competition
and a platinum award at the
international wine and spirits
competition
the highest rating for a canned wine
your
wine was a canned wine going up against
bottled wine correct what did that mean
it definitely changed the industry and
definitely changed their perception
from you know people who are you know in
the judging all the way to consumers
it's helped all around
and what is it about canned wine that is
working because it's existed for a while
but not in the amount that we're seeing
now so what's working with canned wine
now
so it's the price the quality and the
convenience
is really working for consumers and it's
still so new some people don't even know
that great wine can come in a can
and that's what we're trying to really
you know make apparent to the world
is canned wine a game changer for the
industry at all
it's been the most accelerated growth
area in the industry for the last few
years
eric asimov is chief wine critic for the
new york times
it just makes a lot of sense to to put
wine
in cans they're they're lighter they
save money on shipping
people tell me they're easier to recycle
than
than glass does having wine in a can
take away from anything the experience
anything like that
no because of the kind of wine
you're putting in a can you wouldn't put
a fancy wine or a wine that's
intended to age for years in a can
i don't think you should judge wine by
the container
you know the container is is just an
innocent object
you know it's the people who who make
the wine who
are in charge of the quality people like
the damiano's family
i was going to get a bottle but we even
had four bottles right i know
who despite the pandemic continued to
serve wine to their loyal
but now masked customers on long island
thank you guys we'll see you later take
care
all right see you next week as for
angela allison when we caught up with
her last week we learned that wine
society had made inroads in an
unexpected place
restaurants we never thought that we
would be in you know sort of a white
tablecloth environment
but again like not being able to serve
by the glass it opened it up they still
wanted that experience where a customer
could have
you know something on their table
for you now this morning the ultimate
taste test so we've got what we have
we have the bottle here and we have the
can so this is tony wright says it's the
exact same wine
right just put in put in different
places
so let's try this is you're doing the
bottle
very sweet a little tart okay not bad
it's early so you know bottle
be official about this is possible
it tastes a little different i feel like
the can's a little bit sweeter
a little bit you're right yeah it is
isn't it where's the cheese
where's the office where where are the
rest of the hors d'oeuvres um
no it's interesting as as dana notes
there in his uh the
times critic said um lighter saves money
on shipping
easier to recycle seems to make sense
and doesn't appear to taste
that much does one darker looks like
about the same
the analyzation will continue i know and
i see you over there trying to be all
extra with the
before you take it just a drink i was
just going to be famous about it okay
it's 8 43 in the morning you don't have
to be fancy